et comme c'est un test de dégustation on
l'a brillamment appelé nippon ni mauvais
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est une auteure de motus impasse
en vidéo via une vidéo gagner vous
écrivez pour vidéo gars j'ai écrit une
fois pour des riens exactement mais non
avec les honda fit aussi a été à
l'époque on m'avait dit attention
bernard tu mets bien bon soir s'ils ne
le dira pas c'est un beau compliment
vous lui faites c'est vrai et c'est vrai
que c'était marqué sur la fiche du
parfait c'était marqué alors daniel vous
avez brillamment gagné le jeu de frisbee
puisque vous êtes vous rappelle un
tricheur
vous êtes exemptes et ceux qui vont
participer c'est bernard justement alors
bassidji ramener un petit peu les plats
déjà justin jean-michel des mathieux
alors je sors de quatre jours de chasse
aussi écouté mon ami vous faire un beau
week-end revival des gros scores en ce
moment de ces huit financer la chaîne
peut se permet alors vous êtes diffusé
quelques jours vendredi vendredi c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon pour une fois
que vous remettre avant les matches je
venais ici les autres ont gagné
d'ailleurs isabelle et jean notamment
vous est exempt tmm je vais vous dire
vous avez le droit à un petit cadeau à
l'est vous muscler un petit peu on a
ramené ça aussi du japon ccc pour vos
muscles et les lèvres mais lesquels
et avec cette remarque tu comprends
pourquoi tu pourras jamais de prime time
donc là c'est toi avec ta chance je
choisis laquelle alors je pense qu'alors
que les sens oui vous vous êtes dit va
choisir la une parce qu'ils sont leaders
vous avez essayé de piéger
ouais voilà vous dites 1,4 des extrêmes
et veut loyal et l'a3 tout le monde soit
sur l'a3 le 2 septembre il va choisir le
2 le duff alors vous devez goûter et se
tenir vous devrez nous dire ce que c'est
ce sont des servives enfants dès 4
assécher le dre immonde
bien sûr j'avais chanté lauda a mais
l'odeur est très goûté sa famille il
faut manger facilement de thomas c'est
tout
c'est marrant toi allez allez allez
allez pas c'est immonde
alors c'est des cafards sécher n'ont pas
nécessairement audio exactement c'est de
la bonite séchée est ce que c'est la
bonne idée du ton juste et c'est mauvais
aussi mathieu en tout cas le thème du
bon côté toi tu y vas mettre des
salorges alors je vous fais ici c'est là
qu'elle a c'est vrai que c'est pas mon
rapport on peut recouvrir on ma soirée
alors ça c'est des tic tac à s'assurer
du riz japonais ou sinon aussi dans des
soupes japonaise juri haricots verts
cette réforme c'est de les faire danser
alors qu'est ce que ça pouvait alors
commencer à peut-être infruts ça qu il
faut manger il faut manger voilà il faut
manger tous les testicules quelque chose
c'est ficus de gainey ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
talât pas de vous je vous dit tout
cephalon sucette devant moi alors c'est
quoi la paire d'heures qui va dire comme
c'est qu'ils de ses métiers alors qu'est
ce que c'est mais je sais pas mais c'est
pas loin c'est sale et on dirait un
fruit ou un légume ou peut-être non
c'est des prunes salée avec du miel mais
ça c'est bon c'est ça quand j'étais
petit mois ah bon mais c'est bien non
c'est non et bien non ça fait peur votre
vie c'est tout jean-michel salaires et
michel courat le dos de laquelle choisi
celle de poisson je ne pourrais pas et
si c'est le mec j'avais déjà mangé avait
vomi à fort boyard je ne pourrais pas
non plus si c'était bien pour ces
conditions vous dresse à l'aj auxerre
avant on s'est ressaisi des cds al galai
bravo
alors qu'est ce que c'est ça jean michel
jean michel sénégal a cédé zag avec dès
que c'est gratos j'ai écouté c'est très
bon ça c'est bon c'est des algues
marines et très bon jour j les mecs
c'est vrai que ça fait pour ça mais
c'est franchement second point sans
cesse une offensive
je n'ai jamais par contre je me maxime
gagné pour sa merci mais c'est alain
bernard
vous n'êtes pas le choix et c'est face
on voit pas le choix c'est quoi alors
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être ça c'est
bizarre on d'elle de ses comment gérez
vous laissez pas ces spéciales
c'est ça avec rocky la rondelle avec
plaisir c'est mou c'est dur bernard il
sans plus alors on était gentil bien ça
porte bonheur il ira tôt ramadi donc est
ce que vous savez que ce que c'est des
racines de lotus leur est il appelé le
rincon que si on prononce à la france a
fait le roi
bernard est ce que vos pieds c'est vrai
parce que c'est un pic et aussi les
élèves doivent permettre à bernard wis
après c'est vrai que c'est un pays qui
est quand même
réputé aussi pour les résultats pour le
oui pour l'érection et tout ça il n'y a
rien à rien on comptait un cadeau pour
daniel daniel a gagné 2,13 be venez ici
daniel vous a préparé quand même quelque
chose à l'éducation spéciale pour vous
on est là c'est cadeau
je n'ai jamais vu d'aussi grosses
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez là là ça t'intéresse au filet
pas besoin de conseils je vous rappelle
tout ces combustibles mettant ses usines
et de racines et pliable alors c'est
plus oui c'est ça c'est son côté il faut
goûter de dieu est peut-être le déplie
ses crocs où ça se tient alors vu quand
vous tenez je comprends mieux
et toi plaide coquine
[Applaudissements]
vibrante internement c'est du toc avec
tak one est en fait c'est dur a dit
blanc c'est un légume
moyennant quoi la forme parfois c'est la
récupérer on peut le récupérer ça c'est
mon devoir les payer 15 avocats et s'ils
n'ont même pas besoin non plus